le g8 est réuni depuis lundi à paris
autour du dossier de la cybercriminalité
jacques chirac a d'ailleurs plaidé pour
un état de droit sur internet
parmi les principales préoccupations le
détournement des sites réservés aux
enfants ou leur utilisation par des
pédophiles des révisionnistes ou encore
des escrocs face à ces délits il existe
certaines parade explications pierre
nicolas et jean marc l'allier je vais
créer un nouveau pseudonyme pour un
enfant et je vais limiter en fait son
accès aux contenus qui sont présents sur
aol et un certain nombre de sites web
premier fournisseur mondial d'accès à
internet aol vient de lancer son système
de filtrage des sites un service gratuit
qui doit empêcher les plus jeunes de
surfer sur des sites pédophiles raciste
ou pornographique qui sont monnaie
courante sur le web sera peut-être tenté
de taper l'adresse d'un site un peu olé
olé admettons qu'ils tapent sex.com ici
sur tout son cycle
il a tombé sur un panneau qui très
clairement lui la police a well n'est
pas le premier à filtrer les sites chez
info ni où l'on vérifie tout ce qu'on
propose aux jeunes on défend la démarche
tout en reconnaissant ses limites
on a tout à fait conscience qu on est
un espace dans un univers qui peuvent
potentiellement être dangereux donc
évidemment on a tendance à prêcher pour
notre chapelle qui est de dire venez
plutôt dans un espace sécurisé vous avez
malgré tout accès à beaucoup de choses
plutôt que de lancer mon enfant
dans des zones limitées tout fait ce
produit en fait la vigilance des parents
reste l'essentiel même si leur notion de
la violence n'est pas forcément celle de
leurs enfants
les pavots trop souvent tendance à voir
un jugement aplati sur toutes ces
questions à savoir se dire tout ce qui
est violent et dangereux et je pense que
la seule manière d'arriver à ce type est
effectivement menaçant pour l'enfant il
ya des choses qui sont menaçantes c'est
clair c'est de regarder avec eux de
discuter avec eux en l'absence d'une
réelle coordination entre les différents
pays le filtrage des serveurs et la
vigilance des parents restent pour
l'instant les seuls garde-fous pour
éviter les mauvaises surprises ont
peut-être